Gary's got the home theater experience
now so he's like.he al inviting everyone
over yeah like every every minute how
many seats are in the theater eight
seats and three stools you got to sit on
the stool for the Super Bowl
no you could do whatever you want
there's a stool in the theater yeah it's
two rows yeah it goes up and then the
back row there's like a bar like a piece
of granite and their stools I they're
very comfortable stools like seven they
are in a home theater it's not it's not
a bar it's like a to put a couch or
something on the back because I built
the one I wanted not what you want no
but isn't it more comfortable there's
eight seats that's what I wanted the
whole excitement of a home theater is
that you're in a comfortable chain right
but you can also sit back there and you
can have drinks and you can eat and you
know that's the experience that I want
it's a [ __ ] up experience because it's
not your house I'm gonna be any good the
[ __ ] theater want to eagle you kitchen
right that's what you would do because
you've got far too many chairs go across
or like know exactly I'm stupid why do
you care what's in it because I do know
because it's not what you think first of
all it's incredibly comfortable the
stools that they're not really back on
them high back leather chairs I satin up
for the other week and they're very
comfortable sat instead of sitting in
the comfortable chair
well they had a bunch of people over
this is the whole thing this is another
one so you couldn't even get the good
chair my wife is like well we invited
people around like [ __ ] them let them
sit listen what I'll tell you why I'm
right he's right now you are right
[ __ ] I want to sit in my comfortable
chair and swipers know and rightly so
she goes our guests should get the
comfortable chair you sit in the shitty
chair why Why should there be a shitty
chair story into the story it turned out
it was very comfortable yeah sure now I
know you're missing the point you're all
missing here's the point again was he he
rips out those schools are you into the
couch here's the point imagine a nice
just [ __ ] talk you don't we go to
screening rooms we were fortunate enough
a couple of times to be asked by movie
studios to see a movie ahead of time
we'd go in the building and then you'd
have these incredibly comfortable
leather couches and chairs and I have
unbelievably comfortable leather chairs
unbelievably calm yeah but you can't say
that
[Music]
where are you gonna be sick it's rare
everybody's gonna be moving around
actually okay everybody's gonna be
moving around I wouldn't I grab my good
chair understand why you have a man cave
that's where you're supposed to watch
Super Bowl know you're watching it in
the theater yeah that would be dumb to
watch it on 130 inch screen right but I
agree no I think it's great but I just
think the chair thing is beyond in every
room the [ __ ] you want except for you to
cover my [ __ ] house
yeah I'm just saying I guarantee that in
the future you rip that out
you're wrong couch it you're wrong we
love it we've been there we love it we
put some food up there people go back
and have them use it net lucida you sit
at that little marble heaven it's not
it's fine but I don't want you sitting
in the comfortable chairs no no it's a
rarity that it's full okay you're to be
saying all right where's our you're
sitting in the stools for Super Bowl I
don't know where I'm throwing a party so
I'll be moving all around I'll be in the
man cares eight there's eight chairs
that's but he can have 12 chairs and
steady push I don't know that I actually
like a place for PE I actually don't
know that we could have you know I look
at you how many places is he need to
feed well it's not all about me believe
it or not sometimes you want to
entertain people judging by the size of
you it's about you food is getting very
important